c'è un tutti allora non so quanto possa
interessare ma recentemente sono uscito
con una coppia di amici che non vedevo
da un bel po di tempo abbiamo iniziato
facendo i cretini prima ancora di
vederla
abbiamo proseguito affari cretini
macchina cioè che poi davide in
consiglio share fisico da polenta e
l'agilità di un boyscout commissione
abbiamo passato gran parte della cena
improvvisare un karaoke cretino sulle
note di una versione cinese del mondo il
mio con quelle fl pois e finché il tutto
non è degenerato in una versione porno
della canzone cinese il mondo è mio e
quelle in cui tutto ok se non fosse che
a un certo punto contro ogni aspettativa
poi tra parentesi al mio rick pervenuta
la seguente frase sarà io ultimamente di
marchionne sa se tra ovunque vada almeno
una persona che mi lo stesso numero
così è incuriosito mi sono girato verso
la ninfa che aveva convogliato a sé la
mia attenzione con 70 impavida
affermazione mi sono trovato davanti a
un cancello davanti a un ciao
parcheggiato in folli in mezzo al
ristorante davanti e dopo uno scoglio
flagellato dalle onde degli oceani
cercatemi di capire la ragazza non era
manco brutta però quando tu hai l'ardire
di scelte né con una frase di questo
tipo come minimo deve essere megan fox
photoshoppata a un po come quando un mio
amico ebbe il coraggio di uscire il seme
con la seguente frase è che io sono
troppo bello e e nessuna riesce a vedere
al di là della mia bellezza
forse perché non c'è nulla da vedere io
non capisco perché le persone più
pesanti sono quelli che dicono le cose
con più leggerezza e cose assurde escono
così tipo mio fratello mi ha fatto
recentemente scoprire questa cosa su
facebook degli status
dovremmo fare come i fringuelli delle
galapagos di darwin adattarci o morire
il problema è che oggi non esistono più
certezze anche le cose più stupide tipo
stare su un palco sdraiati sull'erba
fredda perché notte estate fissando il
firmamento e magari flirtato
ecco neanche in quel caso puoi
immaginare dove la tua conversazione in
potrebbe andare a finire di sam è
soffermato un secondo a guardare il salo
sì sì sì a volte sì mi mi è capitato è
come fosse la termocoperta della terra e
il sel se mai pensato no non ci ho mai
pensato che questo vi sistemo
un'avventura ha chiamato il suo
programma solo che gol
in verità credo che sta per sky è
presente che le ha lasciato salo
guglielmo non importa dai ma che cielo
che gol ii stasera dico solo che c'è lo
dà però ci sono momenti in cui limonare
più pista davanti è l'unica arma che gli
rimane per evitare una conversazione
piacevole quanto la piaga delle locuste